[Music]
TJ trakis raucous totally jumbled mumbo
what are some of your go-to Christmas
movies each year die hard is a Christmas
movie tis it let's just talk about that
for who and it will be talked about
forever hey you know what we need a
video to go up on Christmas that is
Christmas related views I don't think we
have any we might put out this one we do
weekly Q&A is a burger picture this is
one of those examples maybe this video
is up there just saying that in case
there's more
gosh TJ ever since you had a daughter he
just can't stop talking I tend to lean
towards more of the comedy focused
Christmas movies the Santa Claus home
alone jingle all the way
all three of those movies have shown
over time that there's a lot of
psychologically messed up things with
those characters and what they do today
my dad has made it a tradition to watch
National Lampoon's Christmas vacation
you have literally listed all the
Christmas movies are the only Christmas
mood like actual Christmas movies none
of the movies I like a real Christmas
spirit is those movies right there that
I will a die-hard takes place around
Christmas so does leave the weapons
tonight is home alone I argue that but
at least home alone uses like Christmas
music and stuff like that and there's a
whole decor and it's at home and then
they come home and now I gotta have
Christmas with the family die hard you a
die hard is we went to this haunted maze
made like one of those it's called reign
of terror in October for Halloween and
it's brilliant I like it more than
Halloween Horror Nights and Knott's
Scary Farm and then we went to their
Christmas edition and while it was still
great it was primarily just people
wearing scary masks and a couple of
decor but pretty much the same thing and
that will Christmas a couch or wolf and
but for the most part it was the same
thing and that's what diehard is it's
kind of just cut some Christmasy things
put here in there but it's not a real
Christmas movie doesn't have anything to
do with the messenger spirit of
Christmas so yeah this is my opinion but
if you think that way then okay more
power to you do that's fine yeah I would
say I definitely Santa Claus of mine is
probably my top one
I love jingle all the way I really do
look it down it is so cheese elite dad
but man I eat that I did I love that
felt but it's so fun we watched that so
many times growing up when we would do
those winter like the whole school would
sing a song and the right to wait around
so while waiting we would watch jingle
all the way
yeah like for a few years on it uh home
alone I just can't help but see the
psychological abuse that that inflicts
on Kevin McCallister the whole movie
from his family into the Psychopaths he
turns I do not have that's not even me
like hey I go to footie take or
perception on that's all I see now when
I watch that movie yeah I thought I
couldn't lock into the whimsy anymore Oh
Christmas vacation is a great one that's
a perfect picture for the first time in
a couple a few years ago you know what I
liked I just saw that recently my lady I
right after re-watching I think the last
Jedi we put on know well oh and the new
Netflix or is it do these people uh
sorry Jesus Christ what is wrong with
you control over the camp never do all
kinds of things I really like Noel it is
just it it has the rotten tomato score
it has for a reason it feels like a
made-for-tv movie but it's also on
streaming so you know you kind of give
it a pass Christmas film but I think
it's very charming
and yeah either there was a couple of
the heartwarming touching message
towards the last half-hour that
ultimately led this guy to tears and
there's some genuinely really funny
stuff in it I feel like with Christmas
movies they're not really a high tier
you know there's some great ones of
course but a lot of time I like bad
Christmas movies as long as this smeared
in the energy is there in the family
vibe and stuff I can get on board with
it I'll really judge it as harshly as I
do other films oh yeah there's a level
of like sweetness and saccharine that I
think a Christmas movie if it long as it
drives home by the end the Christmas
spirit in togetherness yeah I feel like
that can make up for a lot of not very
great filmmaking
yes because yeah it's like why are we
here to feel fun and nice and you know -
maybe bond with our family on the bear
some Krampus is a great one I campus
yeah hell yeah Krampus is a perfect one
and oh my god it is it's the original
black and white one with those famous
you've you've got around the corner with
social media oh yeah great why are they
done it yet it's coming don't worry it's
it's coming soon I think I bet I didn't
write that and sell it and make any
money if he finally reveals himself he
just pulls out a dick I know that penis
sitting there and just like that this
video this video
made for adults because that's what
YouTube wants is now D monetized because
it's definitely making fertile hey you
know we use the technical term so maybe
they'll go easy
no they won't no they won't John what
are some other ones you watch oh man
well to get into the Christmas spirit at
home with my family usually a part of
the tradition is to watch meet me in st.
Louis because that kind of traverses all
the different holidays Judy Garland yeah
yeah and actually have yourself a merry
little Christmas comes from that movie
that's good mom so that's one another
classic that I love is It's a Wonderful
Life which I finally got to see in a
theater a few years back which was
wonderful that's that's one of my very
favorite holiday movie did you hear how
he said it
theater theater yes yes look at the mob
movies I love white Christmas is another
one that we watch a lot the white people
yeah why Chris white versus black
Christmas first want to make that joke
black Christmas if you want to get
horror in your Christmas diet that's
also like before Halloween even that's
like the proto slasher and it's
progressive for its time it's actually
really good film um another one is
Miracle on 34th Street both the original
and the remake because my friends so got
a arthur christmas is a animated movie
that i really love that I think kind of
got overlooked the year it came out but
I pull it out every year and it is fun
and imaginative and quite moving what do
you want what's your favorite my
favorite Christmas movies the starways a
Star Wars Holiday Special
oh yeah I got a lovin look at that
Charlie Brown Christmas is the first
picture in the fourth version oh yeah a
little shop around the corner
my neighbor my neighbor solar oh how the
grid the Grinch cartoon as John hasn't
said one
that I know he loves actually huh yeah
was she relating me too
yes yeah yeah that's that's another one
we saw that in the theaters
I fixed it just for you it's Theatre in
the South uh yeah we saw that in the
theater and then for whatever reason
when we were like 40 we really like this
movie and yeah I still it's aged in an
interesting way but I still quite enjoy
Washington I just wants to be on camera
look at you watching out like evil eyes
when you have it yeah I love the
rankin/bass I don't migration specials
this is name of that Kurt Russell Santa
movie that came out mm-hmm
I like that let's not mean that's
unknown I could put it like yeah I know
what you're talking about
Oh was it cold I watched it I if I duck
out in a frame for a moment I can
definitely list in movies that I was
introduced to buy my girlfriend Olivia I
have to mention that speaking of my
girlfriend Olivia let's do our thumbnail
pose in front of them I got our first my
very first first mystery never had one
growing up Emily and I went shopping
around the corner to a local place and
they had this Christmas tree and we
picked it out she decorated the whole
thing and now it's finally gonna be
featured on the YouTube channel with
John thumbnail oh my gosh how do we how
do we make sure let's just move this
thing out of the way yeah we got it like
really just Center the tree and then
yeah oh and don't forget all the
creatures were stirring the horror
anthology movie that I acted in go find
it on VOD let's get a little tighter